i can't just talk about myself i'm only
part of the amazing my videos a lot goes
into making an animated film but usually
it isn't all done from home we're going
to take you behind the scenes of encanto
to see just how the amazing magical
world was created comparing early shots
to their finished product let's go talk
about bruno
we don't talk about bruno we don't talk
about bruno the best work trip ever
the crew actually traveled to columbia
for their research they took inspiration
from multiple locations but specifically
the kokora valley one of the most
beautiful places that bruno actor john
leguizamo has ever been to and naturally
it became the inspiration for the home
of the amazing madrigals we knew this is
where the home of the magical girl
should be we mean this quite literally
a lot of layers go into bringing a scene
to life here's just a few of the fun
ones like this one with the block people
did you realize they were making an m
one animator who designed the block shot
was working from home
so he also found himself using his bed
sheets as a reference for the skirt
motions and we're not sure why some of
these children have white eyebrows but
the blocky movement reminds us of when a
video game character freezes and they
just slide across the screen motionless
and the crowds are just as quirky in
their early stages they're just a little
bit creepy to watch this way too if you
ask us
probably the most visually complex movie
we've ever made the best animators are
the best observers very early on the
discussion about what this story had to
be was centered around family this movie
it's about family and your role within
your family the fate of the family it's
not up to her it's up to you
the sister that carries the world on her
shoulders the outcasted uncle we can all
relate to the madrigals in some way and
part of this is because the writers
really drew from experiences with their
own families to get the movements just
right when you see the details in abuela
know that the animator was studying his
mom when family was on the table they
landed on colombia as the perfect place
for their story because colombia is an
intersecting country of latinx people we
did everything there we you know we went
to lots of cities and lots of towns in
the more rural areas we're actually
going to take a look at all the dance
sequences we could find were you
wondering how they got that incredible
skirt work happening imagine how hard it
would have been for the animators to
block this scene if they didn't have a
reference
we really shouldn't talk about this the
choreographer jamal specifically asked
for there to be latinx dancers as many
colombian and latinx people that can
accurately represent the movement it's
actually pretty incredible to watch how
the choreography was incorporated into
the final scenes part of it didn't end
up being used at all so it's a special
look at what could have been and how
picky and choosy you need to be with the
shots in order to get the story across
jamal sims and kai and the skeleton
dancers really brought the song we don't
talk about bruno to life the actors
would do the whole dance in one take it
would be filmed twice once in skirts and
once in pants so they could get the flow
of the skirts but also so they could get
hip movement and not have it be obscured
all you had to do was just let it take
you see if you can spot any of the
characters based on the dancers moves
alone you can really see the
light-footedness of the dancer
portraying dolores in the scene and
there's so many people that are going to
be influenced by this film not just by
the story you're telling by the
inclusion of the diversity within it an
unlikely group of people sharing
something in common did you know that
animators and dancers share a similar
language and that language is nonsense
they would speak via the sound of the
rhythm but not necessarily putting the
technical words to it bam bam
communication among different mediums
finds a way we guess it makes sense they
communicate in a similar way they both
work with bodies after all just in
different contexts musical theater has
this incredible tradition of telling
story through song
you can do a lot apparently
you can really feel the larger than life
characters and the joy just flowing out
of the dancers in this piece cartoons
often do things like defy the laws of
gravity so we were a bit surprised to
see just how well they captured the
character performance
just an incredible feeling you know
incredible sense of
accomplishment whoever's idea it was to
hire lin-manuel miranda is a genius
the music legend most notably known for
the broadway musical hamilton before
this was brought on board to write the
music for the movie
he was one of the crew who traveled to
colombia to immerse himself in the
culture and get acquainted with the very
specific sound of the music it isn't
common for a disney movie to be written
in 3-4 time miranda said but this movie
was an exception given that time
signature is incredibly important to
colombian rhythm working on a song with
12 very original and different actors it
inspired miranda to find the pulse of
each character and connect them with
different kinds of colombian music
miranda also recorded himself singing
every character's part for we don't talk
about bruno and probably all of the
other music too he finds it the easiest
way to get his intention across here's
hoping disney one day releases a full
album that would be amazing i just said
for the next one can i just please be
there from the beginning i want to be as
involved as i can be this is probably
the biggest project ever done from home
all of the acting and all of the
coaching actually happened over zoom and
the actors worked out of their own home
studios stephanie beatrice who plays
mirabelle admitted that she didn't find
the process all that strange because
voice acting is usually pretty isolated
anyways i'm part of the amazing madrid
she's actually found herself closer to
the director because he was right there
on zoom rather than behind a glass panel
lin-manuel was a huge cheerleader for
the actors he's also incredibly patient
which is good for nervous singers it was
actually adasa's idea to make dolores
sing her lines an octave lower just
above a whisper in the song we don't
talk about bruno that's just one element
that all of that character development
brought to the table
personalization i just felt like a tiger
like i seized the moment
imagine how much has to be in place
before the animators can even start
it's always so cool to look back at the
concept art because it ranges so wildly
in character design and costume you can
see how the early art informs the final
choices but also why some things were
cut like mirabelle was designed to be
wearing heels at one point just imagine
how much that would affect her movement
in the movie taking out those high heels
also would have knocked her down a peg
as high heels can present as very
confident something that she's not from
the start
hopefully bring my best to
mirabelle
casa casa madrigo casita for short the
one limitation the crew were working
with designing the gorgeous madrigal
home was that they wanted the house to
be alive but they didn't want it to bend
to the elements in order to move
that choice really made this living
house distinct from other living houses
and yes there are more remember a movie
called monster house that's just the
first to come to mind the house
expresses most of its personality
through its tile flipping and window
panes they went through a lot of concept
art to get the house just right which is
fair it's as much a character as the
rest of the family the whole movie could
essentially take place in this house but
it was limitless of what it could be
we're about to start nitpicking in a
good way did you see how every single
stitch in mirabelle's capybara patch is
so detailed it's absolutely incredible
how far animation has come even in the
past decade colombian folklore and
personality hints were included in every
one of their outfits even mirabelle's
shoes are intricately detailed but did
you notice the outfits were all
color-coded based on which part of the
family tree you are that was the idea of
the costume designer in order to help
the audience keep the confusing family
tree straight
so there's a lot to be impressed about
and a lot to laugh at what is so
mind-blowing about encanto is that the
first time a lot of the cast and crew
ever met each other in person was
actually at the premiere of the movie do
you think the premiere was awkward for
the cast who'd only ever worked on zoom
or do you think they were having a party
let us know your thoughts in the
comments and thanks for watching